- There's nothing leisurely
about competitive eating,
this is an aerobic activity.
It's like running a marathon
and a hundred yard dash
at the same time except
your feet are standing still
but your stomach is moving
at 100 miles an hour.
(quick classical music)
My name's Crazy Legs Conti.
I've been a major league
eater for 15 years.
I cannot think of a single food
that has not gone
competitively into my stomach.
Make no mistake, competitive
eating is a real sport.
It's muscle memory.
Your stomach, mind and body has it
if you've prepared well enough.
What can go wrong are not
the voices in your stomach
(fast pop music crashes to silence)
but the voices in your head.
"You're getting full, the
contest is going forever,
when will this end?"
Your strategy has to be spot on
in terms of your technique.
But you don't actually taste the food.
At about 15, I start to feel the drag
on pestoly-is in my system.
In competitive eating we call it the wall,
that's where your body just says stop.
You're sweating, your
cheeks are puffed out,
you're exhausted.
The last two minutes are
where dreams are made
and realities are broken.
That's the most difficult
part of any contest.
(bongo drum music)
There is no magic in the
aftermath of competitive eating.
We digest everything we eat.
I need to continually drink liquids
to kind of create a log flume-like ability in my system.
The minimum for any competitive eating
contest is 24 hours before I feel human
and by human I mean as
a casual diner again.
I find the activity of competitive eating
to be grueling and challenging
and esoteric but rewarding.
I'm gonna eat for the rest of my life,
I might as well do it competitively.
(whimsical pop music)